wenn man jetzt über 10 12 13 14 jahre
lang so eine veranstaltung macht und
dann sagt naja von einem jahr aus
nächste geht man dann woanders hin
die haben diese erfahrungen nicht
leipziger straße 130 motto wir befinden
uns hier auf dem ehemaligen tresor
gelände im alten tresor garten was ist
das für ein ort oder was war das für ein
ort und was hat er mit der loveparade zu
tun als die mauer fiel
sind wir sofort alle die 980 schon mit
technik zu tun hatten damals war es ja
noch als althaus aber im weitesten sinne
mit elektronischer musik zu tun hatten
natürlich in den neuen stadtteil für uns
westberliner gegangen und haben wir
gucken was ist sehr grün los in
ost-berlin ja und haben geguckt ob es
darum welche locations gibt man einfach
reingehen kann so das hat ja mit der
zeit immer mehr leute auch nach berlin
gebracht und haben wir zb auch 1995 und
auch später dann der straße des 17 juni
im tiergarten die die loveparade
abgehalten und um die loveparade herum
in den tagen vorher und danach das sind
ganz viele menschen auch junge menschen
und musikliebhaber auch nach berlin
gekommen und haben wir dann auch die
klubs voll gemacht und wir haben zum
beispiel dann hier auf dem alten tresor
garten sind aus wenn väter allem viele
djs aus dem tresor gespielt sonntag
seien immer auch lang gefeiert diese
veranstaltung damals die allererste war
ja gar nicht angemeldet wenn ich das
richtig in erinnerung habe wie kam es
denn dazu wer hatte die idee und warum
wurde das überhaupt initiiert ich habe
ja in der damaligen zeit von 1900
das war glaube ich 86 haben wir im
september die turbine rosenheim
aufgemacht und dort habe ich dann im
september 88 die erste essen acid house
party gemacht und ich hatte dann
geschichten gehört von freunden die aus
england wieder kamen und die haben bei
illegalen wakes mitgemacht weil in den
80ern war ja raven verboten ja weil
margaret thatcher hat damals als eiserne
lady hat dann den weg durchgezogen und
hat gesagt leute die sich auf der straße
zutritt hinstellen es ist schon nicht
erlaubt und auch das tanzen zu sich
wiederholenden rhythmen ist auch nicht
erlaubt
deshalb müsste man das illegal machen
und deshalb haben freunde denn erzählt
mir metern erzählt wie das gewesen ist
dass sie dann auf den partys waren und
nach ein paar stunden kam hat die
polizei und hat dann die party aufgelöst
und hat die anlage kommt konfisziert und
irgendwann hat er dann ghettoblaster
boombox dabei und man hat dann auf der
straße einfach weiter getanzt und diese
ideen
sie liest mir einfach keine ruhe weil
ich wollte das eigentlich nach berlin
bringen und wusste aber nicht wie es
geht und dann habe ich halt da mal
drüber geschlafen und dann war ich
selber auch meine of location eingeladen
und da hatte ich dann morgens die idee
dass man einfach eine versammlung
anmelden
dass man dann kleine waren mit dabei hat
mit der anlage brauchen wir tanzen zu
unserer musik auf der straße und das als
es ankam als aussprach da waren sofort
alle begeistern dann sagt das ziehen wir
durch machen wir und dann haben wir in
sechs wochen haben wir es dann auch
umgesetzt das den damals zu einer
protestveranstaltung oder war das macht
einen anderen hintergrund
ja wenn man jetzt eine versammlung
anmeldet dann braucht man ja einen grund
und ich habe dann halt so ein bisschen
darüber nach was kann man den film grund
nehmen und wollte dann so ein bisschen
was nehmen dass jeder kennt nämlich
friede freude eierkuchen und das habe
ich dann bei der anmeldung auch so
erklären also frieden für abrüstung weil
wir wollten jetzt nicht gegen etwas
demonstrieren sondern wir wollten
eigentlich etwas neues tun und deshalb
haben wir das alles positiv formuliert
was unsere wünsche sind und so denke ich
auch heute noch dass man eigentlich
nicht
gegen etwas sein sollte man gibt ja
seine energie weg die man eigentlich für
seine eigenen ziele er braucht und und
ist so am ende eine andere kraft ist
wenn ich gesagt ich bin immer nur
dagegen also und das bringt ja dann auch
nicht ja weil man ist ja dann nicht am
entwickeln von von einem neuen weltbild
oder von einem guten weltbild das
nächste woche anhalt musik also friede
freude musik als mittel der
verständigung deshalb haben wir zum
beispiel auch keine reden gehalten haben
keine transparente gehalt haben keine
flugblätter verteilt und eierkuchen für
die gerechte nahrungsmittelverteilung
und als ich das dann so langsam
institutionalisiert hat über die jahre
was hat das denn mit dir gemacht und was
würdest du sagen hat es mit der
stadträtin menschen die damit gemacht
haben
ich weiss jemand der schon immer auch
öffentlichkeit stand und von daher war
es für mich jetzt nicht so was neues das
ich jetzt auf den gewann was ja auch
nicht gemacht oder soja das ist einfach
so dass ich eigentlich immer irgendwie
an dem großen traum gearbeitet hatte und
an der vision auch wenn er gearbeitet
hatte dass also die vision die ich bei
der ersten loveparade schon hatte
nämlich dass wir irgendwann dadurch dass
wir das wiederholen jedes jahr andere
irgendwann inspiriert werden ebenfalls
in ihrem land in ihren städten auch eine
parade zu machen und dass irgendwann die
zeit sein wird auf diesem planeten wo
alle länder nach paris haben und dass
irgendwann dann später dann alle
menschen auf diesen paraden tanzen
werden und wir alle merken werden das
sind ja alles menschen weil wir uns im
tanz näher kommen ja und entdecken dann
die vielfalt die andersartigkeit
respektieren das lernen dass auch sehr
zu schätzen und im tanz werden wir dann
halt eine familie und dann merken wir
dass es gar keinen sinn nach
gegeneinander zu kämpfen weil wir haben
alle die gleichen rechte wie haben alle
die gleichen gefühle
wir wollen alle das gleiche wollen also
das gleiche nicht und auf der ebene
merken wir dann das hier wirklich dann
also zusammengehören und dann entsteht
von sich heraus weltfrieden und das war
eigentlich so die idee
wieso habt ihr denn die loveparade oder
die idee der loveparade dann überhaupt
irgendwann verkauft wir haben eine
situation gehabt 2001 wo berliner love
parade asse sich zusammengetan haben und
haben vor uns eine demonstration auf
unserer strecke im tiergarten auf der
straße 17 junis angemeldet und dann
kamen wir und dann hat die
versammlungsbehörde in berlin gesagt tut
uns leid dass ihr kompletter zu spät
weil wir haben schon eine versammlung
auf der strecke deshalb könnt ihr da
leider euren versammlung nicht abhalten
geht nicht also berlin hat uns in zu
verstehen gegeben
ihr könnt die nachwelt in berlin nicht
machen wir hatten ja in die zeiten
vorher keine gewinne ausgezahlt sondern
wir haben rücklagen gebildet die haben
wir nach zwei jahren aufgebraucht und
wir werden 2005 männer weniger insolvenz
gegangen
und das ist dann halt denn dazu gekommen
dass alle gesagt haben wir finden keine
neuen konzepte das weiterzuentwickeln
hatten aber noch einen alten
fünfjahresvertrag so dass dann der
einkäufer der dann im november 2005 200
prozent gekauft hat für viel zu wenig
geld dann die loveparade 2006 noch
einmal durchführen konnte und das war
ich dann so eine parade wo ich sage das
war keine lachparade weil der spirit
nicht dabei war soll das war eigentlich
eine marketing wenn für eine
fitnesskette dann nach dem unglück in
duisburg
hast du relativ bald auch schwere
vorwürfe
schwere vorwürfe erheben ich und du hast
unter anderem gesagt du hättest
befürchtet dass so etwas passieren
könnte
was hat dir die sicherheit gegeben oder
die überzeugung dass zu vermuten
wenn man jetzt über über 10 12 13 14
jahre lang so eine veranstaltung gemacht
und da lernt quasi von total blauäugigen
ersten mal wo wir dann einfach so
ahnungslos sagt wir machen das und
ziehen das durch werden versammlung an
und ziehen das durch
und dann wächst man ja mit der menge der
menschen man merkt wir müssen noch mehr
verantwortung gebracht hat und wann ein
sicherheitskonzept und dann braucht man
irgendwann langen vorlauf und das alles
sauber abzuarbeiten dass niemand zu
schaden kommen also muss die polizei und
feuerwehr also weiter die ganze
erfahrung hat sich die ganze stadt
etabliert also wir haben gemeinsam etwas
entwickelt und wenn man dann sagt naja
von einem jahr aufs nächste geht man
dann woanders hin zum beispiel ins
ruhrgebiet nach essen
die haben diese erfahrung nicht und ich
hatte von anfang an habe ich darüber
nachgedacht und konzentriert was ist
eigentlich da für eine situation
das ist dann bei mir so gewesen dass sie
gesagt haben es gibt keine
erfahrungswerte und das sind eigentlich
standen sind alle überfordert mit dem
thema ja welche rolle spielt die
tatsache dass es ein abgeschlossenes
gelände war und keine offene raum sowie
in berlin
wenn man weiß in duisburg zum beispiel
dass wenn man so eine veranstaltung
macht und man erwartet aufgrund von
erfahrungen die man vorher gemacht hat
über die jahre in essen und dortmund das
wiederum eine million menschen zu einer
veranstaltung kommen dann kann man das
nicht auf ein gelände machen wohl nur
250.000 leute aufpassen
das geht nicht und das ja noch
einzuzäunen und dann über tunnel und mit
einem zu und abgang dass du
regeln das ist eigentlich von vornherein
zum scheitern verurteilt weil die
durchflussmengen zu gering sind und ich
hab dann zum beispiel auch freunden
gesagt die auch dahin wollen und gesagt
komm lass lieber sein bleibt lieber in
berlin
und das hat sich dann leider auch
bewahrheitet weil meine damalige
freundin und jetzige frau elin hat an
dem tag geburtstag gefeiert 2010 in
berlin von familie war eingeladen und
dann um 17 uhr 20 hat mir dann eine
freundin aus frankfurt eine sms
geschrieben der aussage meinte machen
wir den fernseher anderen nachgesagt was
ist denn in dir vorgegangen
was ist denn in die vorgegangen ja ich
war erstmal erschüttert dass das was ich
vielleicht hätte ich das nicht machen
sollen aber ich habe eine vorahnung
gehabt dass das eventuell zu einer
katastrophe kommen könnte und dass sich
das dann bewahrheitet dass dann auch nur
menschen sterben das ist das größte was
man sich gar nicht vorstellen also dass
ein echter der techno szene gewesen dass
das dann halt wirklich so eine
katastrophe kommt in der art und weise
das hätte wie man so denken können
würdest du ganz persönlich aus deiner
erfahrung der events der vorigen jahre
sagen dass bei so einem planungs thema
er die stadt oder der veranstalter in
der pflicht ist
das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab wie
die deutschen gesetze über
veranstaltungen sind ja da gibt es ja
vorgaben über veranstaltungs gesetze und
es ist ja auch so dass hat man auf
youtube zum beispiel auch wir sehen da
gibt es ein video wo rainer schaller als
verantwortlicher und auch inhaber der
veranstaltungs gmbh lopavent ein
interview geführt und sagt er hat jetzt
die verantwortung an seinen
geschäftsführer der gmbh abgegeben
das hier ist der mann der das ganze
verbrochen hat
sascha rhyner übrigens ganz entspannt
hat es um sie herum bleibt aus
jetzt damit 0
natürlich sehr angespannt innerlich aber
ich kann euch nichts mehr machen heute
müssen die operativen kräfte haben die
polizei die sicherheitsbehörden alleine
bei uns die leute in 2000 mann im
einsatz und die müssen richtig malochen
ich kann nichts mehr machen und das ist
eigentlich ein unding dass das überhaupt
möglich ist das ja einfach sagt also
jetzt ist daraus ja das darf eigentlich
nicht sein und das war zum zeitpunkt als
eigentlich schon menschen in der rampe
eigentlich schon übereinander lagen ja
mehr oder weniger also das ist also ich
finde es in undingen also ist auch das
zeigt mir eigentlich auch dass da jemand
ist der hat eigentlich ganz andere
interessen als mitgefühl oder im paket
zu haben
bei auch veranstalter wenn man hat ja
als veranstalter verantwortung nicht nur
auf dem veranstaltungsgelände man muss
man sehen was kommt auf einem gebiet das
man nicht kennt und dann braucht man ja
dann wenigstens leitsystem ja also da
kommen menschen die waren noch nie an
dem güterbahnhof waren noch nie an dem
an dem tunnel war noch nie auf der rampe
und dann gibt es da keinen
ordnungssystem wie man wo man jetzt so
weiter und so weiter
und das ist eigentlich mit ein grund
dafür dass dann die katastrophe
passierte es war ja auch polizei zu
gehen und die hat ja auch keine ahnung
geben damit jetzt um also gab es dann so
eine ansage jetzt per den tunnel da
kommt keiner rein und keiner raus und
dann ging es irgendwann dann um 16 uhr
30 glaube ich oder so ging es dann
wieder auf und dann waren alle zugänge
waren plötzlich auch wieder auf und dann
gab es natürlich von allen seiten mega
druck und dann hat man ja gesehen dass
dann so zehn menschen pro quadratmeter
auf der rampe und im tunnel gestanden
und keiner konnte und wie vorwärts und
rückwärts und das ist so eine situation
wo man eigentlich auch merkt da braucht
es nicht viel um die menschen eine
umkippen zu lassen und dann fallen die
alle übereinander und drücken sich
gegenseitig und das ist ja dann am ende
auch passiert weil es sind menschen dann
über bauzäune die auf der rampe auch
noch umgekippt sind und die leute sind
da drüber weg getrampelt dann quasi
umgekippt und sind über die menschen und
gestolpert und das hat dazu geführt dass
21 menschen gestorben sind
+ ganz viele menschen
schwerer körper nicht traumatisiert
wurden + auch psychisch traumatisiert
wurden die haben wirklich versucht leute
aus dem knäuel rauszuziehen und die sind
dann quasi in den händen die leute dann
gestorben sind blau angelaufen und sind
gestorben und das vergisst man sein
leben nicht hätte man vielleicht einen
hauch tragik aus dieser situation leben
können
die veranstaltung abgebrochen also die
veranstaltung loveparade in duisburg
2010 hätte stattfinden dürfen
und es ist ja auch so dass bis zum tag
selber die behörden in duisburg ja auch
auflagen hatten die bis dahin nicht
erfüllt wurden
und ich hatte mir dann auch überlegen
was hätte ich denn eigentlich als
behörde gemacht ich hätte einfach gesagt
na ja wir gucken mal das was ist jetzt
abriegeln das also keine aufs gelände
kommt bei halt anforderungen nicht
erfüllt wurden und aus diesem grund dann
die veranstaltung dann also keiner
betreten kann und am ende menschenleben
zu schützen
wie bist du für dich dann im anschluss
an dieses ereignis damit umgegangen was
hast du getan um selbst irgendwie einen
weg zu finden das zu verarbeiten
du hast mir stiftung gegründet wenn ich
das richtig verstanden ja ich war ja
erst mal am wochenende danach war die
nature one im hunsrück da bin ich
natürlich auch hingegangen und wir haben
dann auch vor meinem set dann auch eine
schweigeminute gehabt und haben wir
denken ja der opfer von duisburg auch
einwanderer auf gehangen und so weiter
und das kam auch sehr gut an
das war im vorfeld war es nicht gewollt
von der von den veranstaltern der nature
one aber wir haben es dann trotzdem
durchgezogen und ich bin am sonntag
darauf denn ich habe am samstag gespielt
haben soll sonntag mit dem auto direkt
nach duisburg gefahren und habe dann
auch meine mein mitgefühl dadurch
ausgedrückt dass ich nicht nur ein
kniefall gemacht hat und ich habe mich
dann lang aber auf dem auf dem boden auf
den link denn mit den karten habt ihr
abgestellt und hab dann also auch mein
mitgefühl ausgedrückt weil es ist aber
total nahe ich konnte da nicht anders
ich muss sie zeigen und bin auch in den
folgejahren dann auch mal bei den
gedenkt haben auch mal da gewesen
das waren also die fünf jahre in folge
immer da gewesen hattest du kontakt zu
opfern oder an
also ich hab ja viele von den
betroffenen auch auf den treffen den
jahrestagen in duisburg auch immer
getroffen und wir hatten ja im januar
hier auch unsere pressekonferenz weil
wir jetzt mit unserem welche blendet
dann auch losgegangen und gestartet sind
und erweitert dann auch der verein da
weil sich die betroffenen über 20 10 und
die haben auch ihre zustimmung gesagt
also wenn dann kann es auch nur doch
damals in berlin machen wenn wir wieder
eine neue parade machen also die haben
auf jeden fall ihre unterstützung
bekannt gegeben dass der plan eine neue
loveparade zu veranstalten beinhaltet ja
schon auch die idee dass es wieder eine
sehr große loveparade wird also bis zu
eine million menschen könnten
theoretisch kommen wenn wir sagen wir
wollen den spirit jailbreak nach berlin
holen in form einer parade gegen endes
ray player auch als gemeinnützige gmbh
und so nehmen wir die parade auch rätsel
planet gerade die vision war von anfang
an gelernt und wollen wir jetzt alle
menschen auf einer parade tanzen und
dann wird daraus weltfrieden entstehen
und da weiß man natürlich nicht wie
viele menschen werden dann kommt was man
sich also man kann jetzt irgendwas
orakeln
wir gehen jetzt mal von 100.000 euro aus
vielleicht und das ist schon richtig
viel wäre es dann eine anschluss
veranstaltung an das was ihr damals
erlebt habt oder wäre es grundsätzlich
anders also wie würdest du es anlegen
also es gibt sehr großen zuspruch und
ist auch schon lange weil ich werde
schon lange in den sozialen netzwerken
schon immer wieder gefragt und wann gibt
es endlich wieder mal in einem lazarett
in berlin weil alle haben immer gesagt
dass das wohngebiet gezogen ist das
wirklich ein fehler bei der die
loveparade gehört endlich nach berlin
und deshalb machen wir das jetzt auch
wieder
aber testet ihr etwas neues also sagen
wir mal die techno kultur hat sich ja
auch weiter entwickelt in den letzten
jahren und jahrzehnten
was wird anders sein welche beispiele
gibt es vielleicht für andere ansätze
das wird wiederum zustand finden dass es
unsere tradition und das was anders sein
wird ist dass es die musik von heute
sein wird wie damals also es ist ja im
stetigen wandel also es nicht mehr so
dass wir sagen wir haben nur noch 34
stilrichtung das ist ja ganz ganz viele
richtungen es gibt ja elektronische
musik ohne beats bis zu 200 ppm es also
so richtig schneller schneller techno
dann also ob sich aus dem zeitfenster
hat techno house musik cloud technologie
die heute in berlin werden das dann
schmeckt roh und soja also das bitte
sehr also wir drei den eigentlichen feld
vor und sagen wir laden euch alle einen
labels djs clubs festivals um zu zeigen
was wir für eine tolle kultur haben um
am ende auch dazu beizutragen dass in
anderen länder sich wieder inspiriert
fühlen und zu folgen gibt es wird es
irgendeine art von erinnerung an diese
geben oder im vorfeld es wird bestimmt
irgendwas geben und das werden wir
zusammen mit den betroffenen entwickeln
wie das dann aussieht dass wir sehen
also wir haben sie auf jeden fall
gedenken und eigentlich sagt die
betroffenen sagen eigentlich auch sie
wollen ist eigentlich gar nicht wollen
dass die panne wieder stattfindet und
das muss jetzt auch nicht sein also wenn
wir irgendwie dazu beitragen
dass die öffentlichkeit bescheid weiß
darüber was auch jetzt mit dem
abgeschlossenen beendeten prozess dann
passiert ist also jetzt das mache ich
jetzt auch mal nämlich dass die
nebenkläger also die betroffenen selber
betroffen sind dadurch jetzt zum zweiten
mal dass sie ihre prozesskosten nicht
bezahlt bekommen das ist eigentlich noch
eine zusätzliche katastrophe dann müssen
wir uns eigentlich auch sagen wir haben
auch das mitgefühl der stark gibt den
jetzt das geld wieder dann ist gut er
schwamm drüber
und das passiert ja leider nicht sitzen
dann sitzen die betroffenen auf ihren
prozess kosten das ist auch viel geld
was da jetzt gerade bei den einzelnen
dann auch an steht das muss ja auch
bezahlt werde euch dann wieder nicht das
heißt abgeschlossen wird es
wahrscheinlich nie so richtig sein aber
es könnte auch teil der
erinnerungskultur sein dass sie jetzt
wieder so ein großes ereignis plant und
menschen die möglichkeit gibt da
zusammen zu stehen und sich auch zu
erinnern ja ich bin das eine katastrophe
das 21 menschen sterben und wie man das
verurteilt wie kann das sein
findet man dann in der zukunft zu sich
bemühen mit den institutionen so
intensiv zusammenzuarbeiten das da
ähnliche kommunikationsprobleme im
vornherein schon reduziert werden
wir hatten ja
erfahrung entwicklung also wir haben
wissen angehäuft in berlin
und wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel eine
neue parade machen 2021 in berlin
dann haben wir natürlich die auch alle
wieder mit ins boot weil wir dann müssen
wir haben jetzt hier zb angelo plate der
90er die loveparade begleitet hat als
auch zum beispiel den karneval der
kulturen oder auch hessentage auch
sicherheitskonzepte macht und das ist
auch einer mit dem wir dann zusammen
arbeiten werden der natürlich super
pingelig ist ja mit dem wir hören
sprechen kann und der hund werden
natürlich die alten hasen auch alle mit
dabei und die sind auch up to date und
wissen ganz genau was heute für
anforderungen sind und er hat zum
beispiel auch einzige sagt man kann sehr
viel an sicherheit mit einbauen aber
letztendliche sicherheit gibt es nicht
[Musik]